hey guys I'm Ryan right I've been
getting a lot of trailer requests today
I counted I have 32 trailer requests so
that's a lot of [ __ ] trailers I got a
watch and I love it because it's the
best excuse to not do other things that
could be more productive for my life
right now like working out for example
like people are like hey buddy we should
work out like I can't man can't gotta
watch thirty two trailers man please
keep them rolling in keep them rolling
in I love the requests man and the
trailers they tend to be good [ __ ]
trailers
no one's ever commented yet and been
like hey you watch the trailer for this
shitty [ __ ] movie I want to hear you
hate it I mean but if there is one of
those trailers out there please let me
let me see it I just love you guys I
think you guys are just awesome okay
look I live in California I live in LA I
live in the land we're all Hollywood
movies are made quickly I really don't
like a lot of people who are actually in
the film business these days so it's
cool like meet just pure genuine movie
buffs who are like me and just surf the
web and [ __ ] just look up these
trailers yeah so yeah 32 trailers and
I'm gonna watch all of them not not all
one night but I'm giving myself like a
two-week span and tonight I'm not gonna
start off with some [ __ ] trailer no
people are asking me to watch movie
clips of course it's gonna be of a
[ __ ] awesome film
such as the amazing spider-man 2 I'm
really excited for this movie you know
like everyone's kind of worried about
having spider-man 3 syndrome where
everyone's gonna be where it's like oh
there's way too many [ __ ] villains
and you know now that Barack is
president they made a black guy the
villain just kidding I know no one's
made that complaint yet but now so far
it looks [ __ ] sweet you got Andrew
Garfield back who I like more than Tobey
Maguire to be honest can't wait to see
how many people I just pissed off by
saying that Emma Stone who wouldn't want
to bang her Jamie Foxx Academy Award
winner Jamie Foxx who did movies such as
bait Dane to Han D Han or I don't give a
[ __ ] how you pronounce it he's in
[ __ ] um my favorite movie of last
year The Place Beyond The Pines he is
great in that film only film I've seen
him in so far but I have a feeling he's
gonna rock it as Harry [ __ ] Hawes
born taking over James Franco's rule
Road James Franco was acting
the time when people thought James
Franco was kind of a cheesy actor now
he's got a lot of respect Chris Cooper
who I haven't really seen in anything
lately but I remember he's a he's a good
actor Paul G Paul Giamatti Paul Giamatti
my apology amount my Paul Giamatti
sounds like the Joker Paul Giamatti sup
buddy and everyone knows this film's
gonna be the [ __ ] like everyone loves it
already even though they haven't seen it
it just looks shot good it just looks
shot better it looks just better all
around it looks like an epic [ __ ]
spider-man movie so hell yeah
normally I don't watch movie clips I
like to just leave it at trailers alone
clips I feel obviously can give away a
little bit more than trailer camp that's
not necessarily true actually
yeah I like to wait for the clip I like
to wait for the clips when it's composed
into one big movie anyway I'm gonna
watch this one Africa
this is Times Square sniper like I I
don't know anything about if these clips
besides the titles but I from the
thumbnail Jamie Foxx's in this one as
electrolytes electrolytes
and see that I cannot believe
like us so much
so much anger I can see that you see you
don't want to be here is boom I already
feel like goosebumps everywhere see you
wanna hunt anybody
you guys this is my buddy Matt and I
told you about that you're me happy is
this when you me talk walls is there in
it and just be careful great the
electricity I just wanted to see he
makes a move and take that show are you
come with me the music's awesome wait
Molly people okay no oh stupid [ __ ]
that's it [ __ ]
talk about teasing a great scene
I completely forgot I was watching a
little clip I was so hooked right from
the second it started oh man damn that
was [ __ ] smoovies gonna be so good I
love Andrew Garfield that's Peter Parker
I want to be him when I watch the
amazing spider-man movies and that music
is just dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb dumb I
don't know the music sounds like that it
just feels very intense anyway got
another clip to watch here this one's
called Peter and Gwen kiss guess we
haven't seen that yet mm-hm
who's that
this is the maintenance closet this is
the most cliche hiding place you could
have chosen this is this is manipulative
ways take us to the Bahamas as hi this
is they have good chemistry oh that's
hot yeah suck his dick
just do [ __ ] fresh like this is the
plant you get the elevator I distract
okay then we're gonna [ __ ] all night
long
ah uses spidey-senses it's like a Buster
Keaton movie today
from that alone I would have guessed
he's spider-man these are too smart
clips releases you got the dark
intensity one and then you also got like
the light-hearted oh we still got the
comedy thing about Peter Parker there
I'm excited to see this it looks better
I loved the first one that came out even
though it's totally against the reboot
I thought the reboot was one of the
worst ideas ever then I saw it and I was
like this is pretty [ __ ] amazing but
no seriously dude if you're trapped in a
closet with you know [ __ ] Emma Stone
make your sucker dick anyway guys thank
you for suggesting that watch that that
was great that's great you know watching
stuff like this you totally forget about
everything else that's what I love about
it trailers alone can be escapism and
it's awesome oh yeah um subscribe too
that'd be nice if you did that first
time watching subscribe if you love me
subscribe if you like me subscribe if
you hate me don't subscribe